foreign
[Music]
for Friday February 3rd I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
this week Tick Tock brought a group of
journalists on a tour of its new
transparency and accountability Center
just outside Los Angeles it's the latest
step by the popular social media app to
calm concerns from U.S lawmakers and
Regulators who worry tick tock's Chinese
ownership exposes the app and by
extension its users to oversight by
Beijing it's part of a host of steps
Tick Tock is taking to give more insight
into how its systems work but it's not
the first company to try this strategy
with me to discuss the new center and
its possible impact is our social media
reporter Georgia Wells hey Georgia great
to have you back on the show thank you
for having me so you visited this
transparency and accountability Center
what was it like tick tock's
it felt like a museum exhibit or like
The Visitor Center for a national park
or some other kind of curated display
you might visit and so you walk in and
it has these big computer screens or
digital screens that show different kind
of curated Snippets of information about
the company's privacy policies and how
the company makes moderation decisions
and different tools the company has for
teen users or family ways that families
can use tick tock together and then also
in this cluster of rooms there's these
computer modules where you can try your
hand at kind of moderating tick tocks
videos the way some of their thousands
and thousands and thousands of content
moderators have to do it so it was a way
to learn more about tech talk in a way
that the company wanted to teach people
about is kind of role in the world who
do they expect to bring through this
Center apart from journalists they
brought in the other day Tick Tock is
looking to bring Regulators lawmakers
possibly academics like anybody who has
a serious interest in Tick Tock in its
future in this country can you tell us a
little bit about the context for why
Tick Tock is doing this Tick Tock has
been working with you U.S Regulators for
more than two years to try to convince
them that there's a way that Tick Tock
can kind of create this Standalone unit
in the U.S to operate and the whole goal
here is to try to alleviate concerns
that the Chinese government could
pressure tick tock's Chinese corporate
owner to either collect data on
Americans or serve them or influence the
content it serves to its users what is
Tick Tock trying to do with this move
Tick Tock appears to be trying to adjust
its Public Image to be a company that
kind of shares more information
proactively Tick Tock actually started
working on this transparency Center back
in 2020 that was around the time when
the Trump Administration was talking
about banning Tech talk so clearly like
Tech talk was in the hot seat at that
time but then the pandemic obviously
delayed the creation and opening of this
transparency Center but these concerns
about tick tock's relationship with this
Chinese parent company have been
lingering for a really long time time
and Tick Tock is I think hoping to see
some closure in the next year on these
issues it appears that this like
transparency campaign is one one piece
of tick tock's effort to convey that it
is operating more transparently we talk
about lawmakers being upset with Tick
Tock is this something that lawmakers on
both sides of the aisle agree on
so we're starting to see a lot more
bipartisan consensus that something
needs to happen with Tick Tock if you
rewind to mid-2020 the concerns around
tick tock were actually usually more
Republican lawmaker concerns but now
we're seeing more and more democratic
lawmakers Express similar concerns Mike
Gallagher is a really good example of
that it's so then how much of an impact
do we actually expect this Center to
make given that growing bipartisan
concern it's hard to like quantify how
much of an impact this could have but I
think that it's just like one piece of
tick tock's new campaign to try and um
use transparency to build some trust in
Washington so
I know like the future will tell whether
or not this kind of makes serious
inroads this strategy this transparency
Center strategy we've seen it before
right Huawei so Huawei is notable
because it's the other main sort of
success story of a consumer brand from
China that really made it big outside
China that also face kind of similar
concerns from regulators and in 2019
Huawei opened what it called the cyber
security transparency Center in Brussels
and Brussels as you know is the home to
the headquarters the EU
and so at that opening back in 2019 a
Huawei executive said that they hoped to
like showcase the company's cyber
security practices and so Huawei was in
this similar position of trying to
convince Regulators there that it could
be trusted to operate in a way that we
protect customers from any influence
from the Chinese government so how
successful was the strategy then for
Huawei and Brussels so in Brussels it
didn't work that well many experts
expressed skepticism about what Huawei
was trying to show them tick shared some
other news this week about its algorithm
right so Tick Tock also shared more
details about how its apps moderation
system and algorithm systems worked and
so this also appears to be kind of part
of a broader offensive tactic to try to
kind of share more with users include
users more ahead of some decision making
so that people understand better why
they're seeing what they're seeing on
the app in Georgia you were speaking
with us just the other day about these
changes that Tick Tock is making I mean
they keep coming out with new strategies
what happens next so Tick Tock is still
trying to convince U.S lawmakers and U.S
Regulators that this system to Silo off
a portion of its operations in the US
could work but meanwhile we've got some
bills to ban Tick Tock kind of winding
their way through Congress so it's
really a question mark right now how
this is going to pan out for tick tock
all right that's our reporter Georgia
Wells thanks for joining us Georgia
awesome thank you for having me and
that's it for Tech news briefing this
week tnb's producer is Julie Chang our
supervising producer is Melanie Roy and
our executive producer is Chris sinsley
I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks for
listening have a great weekend
foreign
[Music]